i believe it's dysfunctional
okay tell me why
because
men and women are different they're
biologically different they were made
that way
and so they have different desires
inherently of what they want and the
modern standard in my opinion just
doesn't work
okay what do you think is a modern
relationship
uh
it's a bit tricky to answer you know
because it's like
it depends
on your age
also your
way you are as well background and then
also religion comes into it as well
so it kind of differs but i would say
modern relationships now
are i would agree with you linda they're
dysfunctional unless you
you're able to communicate and stuff but
it's hard to say this is a modern
relationship every relationship is
complicated
yeah okay what do you think of the
modern relationship i would agree with
that where this below a certain age
it's
possibly dysfunctional because
there isn't defined roles and maybe
there isn't discussions up front about
you do this i do that you know
and both of you picking up the slack and
doing your parts
and i think
some modern relationships are
dysfunctional because
people don't
communicate those expectations up front
okay what do you think
um
i think expectations
there's a bit of a blurry line now
nowadays i think
sometimes women
earn more they do more
sometimes men do
the same so i think sometimes it's not
it's it's not
it's not as it used to be um
it's clearer before right
in a way
i think young people don't they don't
want it to be clear i think it's just
the way it is blood that's an
interesting point
how has dating changed over time
i think it was quite i don't know if it
was simpler
meeting someone i think nowadays it's
harder to meet someone
although everyone does dating online but
it seems harder still to
to drum up communication for someone to
speak to you people normally speak
through texting yeah so people don't
although everyone's got inclusive
minutes they're still texting so that
it's quite impersonal i find dating
nowadays
and i think back in the day was they say
it was easier people more accommodating
people more open i'm not sure people
that open now
would you say um because a common
complaint i hear from men is that
women's standards are too high would you
say women's standards have gotten higher
over time or has it always been like
that
they're unexp i think they're
unrealistic their expectations are
unrealistic
so
we a young person might say i'm just
going to say a young person might say i
want a guy who
i don't know drives he's got somewhere
to live and he he should be earning xyz
um they want that for someone but they
don't really want that for themselves so
the guy has to level up
but the girl doesn't have to level up
yeah she just has to be
available there
which is would you guys say that the
dating apps has exacerbated that
progression so like i feel like the
dating apps skew
that to a large degree
because
like we have the stats right where
only 20 of guys are seen as eligible
whereas i think in real life
you might chat to a guy you wouldn't
swipe right to
and there's that
removal of like a human element you know
and the biggest things for long-term
relationship success pretty much has
nothing to do with your looks
yeah
you know
um i would say that
yeah it's made it worse i don't i don't
think social media has made
relationships better which is
interesting because we have more ways to
talk to people than ever
but it seems like we're more distant
yeah
it was weird because like we before
um
like i i had german nannies growing up
and it would be really hard to keep in
contact with them because of like
you know like skype was kind of iffy and
it just it just was harder when i was
younger and now it's so easy
but
even with all this technology it's like
we all talk less it seems like
definitely
and people's social skills like
after all the craziness the last few
years i think everyone's social skills
just took a hit
and
even people who claim to be extroverted
you know they
would happily say oh you know i have
friends that were more sociable than me
in a way and now they're just like happy
to chill at home
and i think
i think you can actually set yourself
apart
like in previous experiences i've had
just going up to someone having a
conversation is almost unheard of now
that
obviously we can get into all the
expectations to get into a relationship
but just to open the door and speak to
someone
i actually think is easier than people
would let themselves on
now initial attraction is obviously a
factor in that right but i still think
that you can set yourself apart just by
being nice being in interest in someone
would um would you girls agree like i i
think as a girl like if a guy actually
approaches you in person i'm more likely
to say yes than if he like dm's me on
instagram or on a dating app or
something
like to giving him my number would you
agree or disagree um
depending i agree for sure i mean i
don't use dating apps i only go based on
person because
um
like for me it's it's the aura that they
have it's the way they approach you are
they overtly sexual right away are they
asking interesting questions uh what did
they choose to ask about me sort of
thing and just it's it's easier to kind
of explore their mind on a dating app if
i didn't like how someone looked i could
be swiping uh what's the direction
of your original
left left i could be rejecting like
my future husband that i have like so
much in so much in common intellectually
and and values when guys don't take good
pictures i think in general
so i
on this point i said someone close to me
swipe right on five guys not that you
find really unattractive but just
you have a
kind of type but just bend the rules a
little bit swipe right on five guys and
just see where it goes
just do it because
you never know
and
i think everyone that's been in a
relationship here i think could agree
that
yes looks are important yes you need to
be attracted to your partner but there
is so much more
that everyone requires to stay in a
long-term commitment money
did you say money
just started yeah no i wanted to make a
point from the all because i didn't have
a chance to speak i was about to ask you
sorry
so many things i just wanted to say um
yeah as she said i feel like your
relationship are just mostly like super
like superficial and toxic
first so in fact that social media is
there now so obviously now everyone got
a fake expectation like not realistic
expectations because of what you see but
i was also how people what people showed
you
now if a guy just always shows me like
richard milley jewelry money
because approach me i am expecting you
living that kind of lifestyle now if i'm
seeing you and then you're just a normal
guy having a nine-to-five you're not
entrepreneur you don't own what you
claim you own i'm not gonna date you
anymore because you're lying so why
would i date you he's like me if i will
go with my instagram and just photoshop
my pictures like i got big like nice
body bbl big everything now i'm going
and i can be a different person the guy
was like why you lie
but at the same thing would you say
women are lying when they use filters
then i believe they got to the point
where they get so like insecure but they
look because they keep like constantly
like
compete with people that they see
they're not realistic
beauty standards if that makes sense
like you cannot compete for like a king
kardashian or some alexis sky for
example and then
i don't really see the point on doing
that personally
but um going back on the dating thing i
feel like it was really really bad
before especially after covid yeah
people don't they have like social
anxiety i see they got any more
introvert because they got used to
staying home
but at the same time
i don't know i feel there's no like
there's no willing to communicate
anymore to be honest anymore not even
too personally i'm gonna be probably
unpopular opinion i like a guy they can
provide for me like they have actually a
good job stable job because as a man you
are actually meant to provide for the
woman you need to make me feel like i
can count on you if i want to open a
family life family right i can't be with
someone that got no job lose their mom
no money why would i do that
but on the same point i believe it got
so
toxic to the level that you can't be but
like honest anymore does that make sense
because everyone lies a lot maybe thanks
to social media as well i don't know if
that makes sense
so even the in-apps as well as tinder
for example that is to probably
over-sexualize now so i use their okay i
use that
and i always had like really bad
experience because guy will just come up
with you for the wrong intentions like
oh let's go out so i can bring you back
with me and it's not what i'm you know
what you look what i was looking for at
the time so that was actually my next
question um who have you has been on a
dating app and as many of you know i was
just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible